>>Van Jones: Hello, You Tubers. My name is
Van Jones. I'm with an organization called
Green For All. We're sister organization for
the Ella Baker Center for Human Rights in
the United States of America.
I think that one thing we all need to be focused
on is building a green economy that is strong
enough to lift millions of people out of poverty.
The two big issues that are gonna be with
us, are going to be the incredible ecological
crisis that we're in. The ecological destruction.
And also the social crisis. The widening of
the gap between rich and poor in all of our
countries and all around the world.
While both are two slightly different problems,
there is one solution. And that solution is
to build a green economy that's strong enough
to lift people out of poverty.
We're focused on the question of green collar
jobs. We're working to get green collar jobs
for low income people.
Our idea is we have all this work to be done
to retrofit the way we do energy all around
the world. There are millions of buildings
that need to be weatherized. There are millions
of solar panels that need to get put up. There's
millions of wind farms and solar farms and
wave farms that need to be built. So we can
have energy without destroying the planet.
That's a lot of work and there are millions
of people who don't have work.
I believe the moral challenge of the new century
is to connect the people who most need work
to the work that most needs to be done. And
that way we can fight poverty and pollution
at the same time.
If you are an entrepreneur or business person
you should be going green. You should be going
green and clean. You also should be thinking
about how could we use the fact that we have
all this work to be done now and doing it
a different way to employ people maybe you
haven't employed before. The ladder out of
poverty - we need green pathways out of poverty
and into prosperity, into community, into
dignity.
This is possible through the business community
saying we are going to deal with this problem
on both sides of it. We're going to be more
fair toward our workers, we're gonna be more
fair to the communities that we're involved
in. We're going to adhere to the highest standards
with regard to labor and with regard to the
environment. It's a key role for business.
And as far as government is concerned, the
governments around the world right now are
partners mainly to the problem makers in the
world. They're partners to the war mongers,
the polluters, the incarcerators, the people
who are doing destructive things. The governments
of the world need to get on the side of the
problem solvers in the world. On the eco entrepreneurs,
the solar industry, the coaches, and the counselors,
and the teachers and the artists. The people
all around the world who are trying to make
a difference, but who feel like it's all uphill.
If the governments in the world were problems
to the problem solvers in the business community
and the and the problem solvers at the community
level, we would beable to see a green wave,
a green wave that can lift all boats. That's
what we should all be focused on.
Thank you. I'm done.